>> Jesse: DANA MENTIONED NOISE
FROM WASHINGTON.
>> Greg: YES, THE NOISE.
>> Jesse: I HAD A POLL OF MY
SHOW, "WATTERS' WORLD."
87% OF AMERICANS ARE SICK AND
TIRED OF THE NOISE COMING FROM
WASHINGTON.
>> Greg: I LOVE THE FACT THAT
MEDIA IS UPSET ABOUT TRUMP
RESPONDING.
THEY LIKE THE SUCKER PUNCH, LEAK
INFO TO THE MEDIA AND SURPRISE
TRUMP OR SURPRISE A REPUBLICAN,
THAT'S HOW YOU DO IT.
IT WAS ALWAYS ABOUT THE SUCKER
PUNCH FOR THE LAST THREE YEARS.
YOU HAVE A LEADER WHO PUNCHES
BACK.
AND EVERYONE'S GOING LIKE, OH,
MY GOD, DID YOU SEE WHAT HE SAID
QUICKLY GET BY THAT THAT HE'S
NOT TAKING IT LYING DOWN.
PELOSI'S VOTE SHOULD TELL YOU
ABOUT THE CIRCUS.
NOT A SINGLE REPUBLICAN VOTED
FOR THE INQUIRY.
DESPITE THE MEDIA AND THE NEVER
TRUMPERS WISHING IT TO BE SO.
IT'S GOING TO BE DOA AND IT'S
GOING TO BE A SELF-DESTRUCTIVE
FOLLY.
IMPEACHMENT WOULD BE GREAT FOR
THE DEMOCRATS AND THE MEDIA OR
MAD THAT, AS ALEC CALLED THEM.
THEY DID SOMETHING TO KEEP BUSY.
THE DEMOCRATS
OUR ABILITY AND CAPPING
THEMSELVES WITH A LOSING BATTLE.
THIS WILL HAVE AN EMOTIONAL
FALLOUT THAT'S WAY WORSE THAN
THE BACHELOR AT THE VERY AND
MAKE GETTING A NO.
IT'S LIKE HOW THE COLLUSION
THING DESTROYED THEM FOR MONTHS.
THEY COULDN'T LEAVE THEIR HOMES.
THERE IS GOING TO BE NO
WATERGATE AND HE'S GOING TO WIN
REELECTION.
THIS IS THE MOST TRANSPARENT
CONSPIRACY THEORY IN HISTORY,
AND SEEK A PHONE CALL DONE IN
PUBLIC WHICH TELLS YOU THE
INTENT.
IT'S NOT THAT HE'S ABOVE THE
LAW, IT'S THAT HE'S ALSO NOT
BENEATH THE LAW.
YOU CAN'T COME UP -- LASTLY,
EVERYONE OF THESE CONCERNS IS
ABOUT SOMETHING THAT HASN'T
HAPPENED OR -- SOLD RECENTLY,
THE UKRAINIAN AMBASSADOR --
>> Juan: VOLKER?
>> Greg: THEY ASKED HER ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP'S COMMENTS.
SHE SAID SHE DIDN'T KNOW WHAT
THE COMMENTS MEANT.
THEY TALK ABOUT SETTING THAT
DOESN'T EXIST.
>> Emily: SO SHE'S A PUBLIC
SERVANT.
SHE DIDN'T SAY ANY OF THIS UNTIL
SHE WAS CALLED BY THE DEMOCRATS